[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview notre invité
cette semaine c'est henri guaino henri
guaino bonjour vous êtes installé dans
un studio manger dans paris à caumartin
de façon à être à l'abri des risques dus
qu'aux vide 19
nous sommes bien obligés de respecter
toutes ces contraintes sanitaires henri
guaino vous publiez actuellement un
livre qui vient de sortir sur le
gaullisme au moment où l'on commémore
bien sûr l'anniversaire de la mort du
général de gaulle se livrent ses deux
goals le nom de tous ceux qui nous
manque c'est le nom le deuxième nom que
vous avez choisi vous êtes
un bon connaisseur du gaullisme vous
êtes un des derniers représentants de
pour porter cette doctrine ou cette
attitude vous avez toujours défendu une
ligne gaulliste jacobine
on en reparlera aux souverainistes
peut-être on va y revenir
donc ce livre a été publié aux éditions
du rocher alors c'est pas un livre sur
le général de gaulle à henri guaino
c'est un livre de méthode c'est un livre
de lecture du général de gaulle oui
c'est pas la énième biographie sur sur
du général de gaulle y en a d'excellents
tu pouvais pas rajouter quelque chose de
plus à tout ce qui a déjà été écrit sur
sa vie et son oeuvre donc mon moi en mon
sujet c'est est-ce que ce que ce qui
s'est passé quand le général de gaulle
tête au pouvoir a quelque chose à nous
apprendre sur sur nous-mêmes et puis
répondre à la question mais pourquoi
donc les les politiciens aujourd'hui où
la plupart d'entre eux se croit-il
obligé de faire référence au général de
gaulle pourquoi ont-ils le sentiment que
dans l'opinion ce nom évoque de plus en
plus qu elle quelque chose et ce quelque
chose que je décris dans mon livre c'est
de au fossé le sait le vit le vide ville
les français se rendent comptent de plus
en plus que
il leur manque quelque chose qu'il ya un
vide que les politiciens n'arrivent pas
à remplir aujourd'hui et ce vide lui ont
donné un jean donner un nom il le
rappeler de gaulle c'était voilà je sais
la comparaison entre ce cas ce qu'a été
le général de gaulle ce qu'il a accompli
la son rapport à la politique son
rapport à la france
est ce que les politiciens d'aujourd'hui
ou si on veut être plus gentil des
responsables politiques ne sont plus
capable de l'incarner
oui alors c'est très intéressant l'idée
c'est quand même de savoir si dans cet
héritage il ya des choses qui seraient
reproductive qu'on pourrait utiliser de
façon à nous sortir un peu des
difficultés de la crise que nous
traversons il ya quand même de sacrés
coups de piques à l'encontre de la de la
classe politique vous dites les
politiciens ce pas très c'est un peu
péjoratif vous avez raison mais c'est
des politiciens qui aujourd'hui le mec à
toutes les sauces mais qui autrefois un
ou même leurs aînés du même courant
politique et bien été en opposition
totale flagrante avec le général de
gaulle oui tout ça morial disaient
qu'ils le veulent avait tout avait tout
le monde contre lui c'était déjà le cas
quand il était en tout cas tout le monde
les tous les jours presque tous les
journaux de l'époque une bonne partie de
la droite la gauche le centre
et puisque mauriac appelé les dîners en
ville à dire une partie aussi de la de
la bourgeoisie dans 10 aces qui
disait-il dans l'est dans les dîners
commença à vomir sur le général dès la
première gorgée de whisky
ça ça n'a fait que se poursuivre et
s'amplifier dans l'après gaullisme la
vérité c'est que le gaullisme n'est pas
une doctrine c'est pas un catéchisme
c'est pas s'est il n'ya pas d'héritage
doctrinale du gaullisme c'est une grâce
tic 10 gouvernance voilà non c'est une
histoire c'est une histoire c'est une
histoire qui commence le 18 juin 1940 et
qui s'achève en 1969 avec le référendum
perdu sur la régionalisation camp de
gaulle décide de quitter le pouvoir
parce que il estime que les français ne
lui ont pas témoigné à cette confiance a
traversé la réponse à ce référendum qui
lui tenait à coeur bienvenus donc la
question aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si
cette histoire c'est à dire ce que le
général de gaulle à incarner et ce qu'il
a accompli pendant toutes ces années
nous apprend encore quelque chose sur
nous mêmes sur notre présent sur notre
avenir
si nous avons des leçons en tirez sur
l'art de gouverner et sur la façon
d'aimer la france sur la manière d'être
un homme d'état je crois que c'est
c'est ça qui est important maintenant il
bien sûr dans cette façon de gouverner
qui a été celle du général de gaulle
dans cette danse ce qu'il a incarné il y
a quelque chose qui remontent à bien
bien plus loin que les années 40 50 60
le général de gaulle en fête a été le
continuateur d'un preview très anciens
courants de pensée français d'abord
malraux disait le nom du 18 juin fait
écho à celui de jeanne d'arc et à celui
d'antigone c'est vous dire s'il il en
chercher l'origine très très loin mais
il n'avait pas tort ça n'était pas
qu'une qu'un effet de style le
ce courant c'est d'abord celui qui
trinque on prend si pour beaucoup de nos
nos partenaires étrangers celui de tous
les grands personnages de l'histoire qui
ont maintenu la france envers et contre
tous dans les pires dans l'est dans les
pires moments de son histoire dans les
moments où elle allait se allait se
défaire donc tous ceux qui ont cru que
la france avait une vocation
exceptionnelle sur la scène du monde
tous ceux qui ont cru que la france
était inséparable de de la grandeur mal
mais aussi m henri guaino régie c'est ce
que pardonnez moi ce que ce que ce que
vous dites est très important on va
essayer d'être un peu plus précis sur ce
qu'est le gaullisme et parce que vous
avez beaucoup de jeunes qui n'ont jamais
appris ce qu'était de gaulle à l'école
dans les livres d'histoire avoue que
vous avez raison mais on n'a pas
traversé philosophe il n'a pas fait
traiter de de gestion politique c'est
par la kabbale c'est nous notre
génération on s'en souvient parce que
nos parents mais mon père m'a initié ou
général de gaulle était dans la
résistance
et puis j'ai encore un vague souvenir de
mai 68 mais concrètement si vous aviez
deux ou trois mots pour caractériser ce
que vous appelez la méthode l'attitude
l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi alors d'abord les
principes qui ont qui ont gouverné le
l'action du général de gaulle + moi je
dirai tout d'abord l'indépendance de la
nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et en
femme quelque chose de quelque chose
d'autre qui est une cause d'une
conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale voilà ce
qui nous renvoie à des questions qui
sont aujourd'hui des questions d'une
grande actualité c'est de gaulle nous a
rendus
ce que les crises terribles du xxème
siècle nous avait enlevé à la fois la
débâcle de 1940 les spasmes de la
décolonisation les turpitudes de la fin
de la troisième et de la quatrième
république
il nous a rendus d'abord des
institutions qui permettent à la france
d'être gouvernés et nous a rendu un état
digne de ce nom
il nous a rendu une indépendance
nationale que nous et nous avions perdu
nous avons d'une unité en nous évitant
autant 44,58 une véritable guerre civile
à chaque fois il nous a rendus aux six
ce quelque chose sans lequel il peut pas
y avoir une nation qui s'appelle la
fierté nationale et tout ça a été jeté
par dessus bord dans ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la prime holisme c'est à dire on
va dire après la mort du général mais
moi je dirai après la disparition de
georges pompidou qui quoi qu'en pense un
certain nombre de gaulliste orthodoxe
n'est pas un traître à la cause à la
cause gaullienne il a la lourde tâche de
succéder au général de gaulle il l'a
fait à sa façon il n'était pas de gaulle
et il ne se prenait pas pour le pour le
général pas plus d'ailleurs que
contrairement à ce que pensent et aux
aides de général ne se prenaient ni pour
napoléon ni pour jeanne d'arc mais
général la natalité l'imitateur de tous
les grands personnages d'un arrêté le
continuateur bon à sa manière en tout
cas s'agissant de l'autorité de l'état
et de l'unité l'un n'est pas en français
georges pompidou a plutôt hâte qu'ils
n'étaient pas qu'elle ait pas fait le 18
juin plutôt accompli convenablement sa
tâche après commence vraiment une
période où l'héritage
et dilapidé volontairement ou pas deux
soeurs nous ont gouvernés de ce sont
ceux sans poser en s'opposant à
l'héritage gaullien voit la situation
était le nom d'un gant dans cette
histoire est que vous racontez très bien
c'est que georges pompidou finalement
était pas un politicien au départ il n'a
pas pu me faisait pas de politique
il était donné dans la dans la banque
d'affaires rothschild et c'est un
représentant de cette grande droite
enfin laurie général oui c'était une
grand un représentant qui qui critiquait
quand même beaucoup général de gaulle 1
donc et l'autre à lyon ce mot là qu'il a
eu à la mort du général de gaulle
le général est mort mais la france est
veuve général de gaulle est mort la
france la france est veuve mais non mais
faut pas peut pas trop simplifier cette
histoire d'abord georges pompidou à
l'origine n'est pas un mao khê
d'affaires c'est un professeur de
lettres classiques qui est qui écrit une
anthologie de la poésie française d'un
homme pétri de culture et de littérature
et qui comprend très bien ce lien
étrange mystérieux mais si fort entre la
france et sa lite et la littérature
mot-clic prépares tu que d'une certaine
façon françois mitterrand avait avait
compris aussi mais que beaucoup d'hommes
politiques de responsables politiques ou
non non non jamais saisies qui fait que
n'ont jamais vraiment compris ce
qu'était ce qu'était la france mais
georges pompidou il faut s'en souvenir
c'est pas un politicien c'est d'abord le
l'incarnent d'abord le l'idéal de la
promotion républicaine de là
pour troisième de la troisième
république puisque il est le fils assis
des fils d'instituteur ine dans un dans
un dans une région très très rurale il
restera les pieds enfoncés dans dans la
terrell son enfance jusqu'au bout et en
même temps même temps si j'ose dire mais
sans lui donner la signification qu'on
lui donne aujourd'hui il est un homme la
littérature il fait normale sup
il va faire un passage au conseil d'état
mais il est aussi un amateur de un
amateur d'art moderne architecture
moderne et il sera aussi le premier pour
s'en souvenir cet homme qui est un homme
des trente glorieuses qui a été pendant
six ans le le premier ministre du
général de gaulle et qui a été une sorte
de colbert bravo paul du xxème siècle
pour le général de gaulle qui était pas
du c'était pas du tout un libéral sens
on l'entend aujourd'hui à ces têtes
c'était un homme qui croyait à
l'autorité de l'état qu'ils croyaient
que l'état avait quelque chose à faire
pour moderniser le pays pour moderniser
l'industrie
donc il était à la fois littéraire
industrialiste colbertiste et mémos
dernier sur un tas de sujets ça a été le
premier à faire des discours sur
l'environnement sur les rapports de
l'homme avec la nature et c'est lui qui
a créé le ministère de l'environnement
voilà c'est donc c'est un homme qui
continue cette cette tradition
gaullienne qui est une tradition à la
fois de référence profonde à l'histoire
au passé et en même temps de tourner
tourner vers l'avenir tenez vous tourner
vers la vers une forme de modernité très
très très forte
alors je vais arrêter de lutter de faire
le dos rond faire l'histoire je
comprends bien votre plaidoyer est
d'ailleurs georges pompidou assurer le
passage entre le gaullisme et puis ce
qui s'est passé un peu après notamment
en matière de développement économique
oui ce que j'ai regretté ces camps c'est
que l'attelage
en 69 de georges pompidou et de jacques
chaban delmas qui étaient 2 qui
représentait deux faces de ce qu'avait
pu être le gaullisme deux l'un plus
conservateurs d'une certaine façon
sûrement sur le sur le plan des moeurs
épais et plus progressistes et l'autre
plus souvent voilà nous fait plus
tourner vers le prêt social plâtres avec
la nouvelle société notre garage de
panache ils formaient ensemble ils
formaient ensemble au fond parce qu'ils
étaient de police se sont pas entendus
pour des raisons qui tenait pas
seulement aux idées mais mais aussi au
caractère au tempérament ça ça a été le
grand dommage enfin pour moi le grand
regret qui a accouché d'une de la suite
de l'histoire de la liquidation ensuite
dû l'héritage mais hélas que vous
décrivez c'est l'arrivée dans l'époque à
l'époque actuelle on se retrouve dans
deux minutes
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec henri guaino pour ce
livre qu'il vient de sortir sur deux
beaux le nom de tous ceux qui nous
manque aujourd'hui on a beaucoup parlé
de ce qu'il est de ce qu'il a fait de
son histoire qui est un moment très
important dans son dans la connaissance
de cet héritage
je voudrais henri guaino vous vous
interrogez sur l'applicabilité
aujourd'hui de toutes les idées
gaullistes et vous demander si en fait
y'a pas un malentendu dans dans ce que
vous et vos amis parfois dit à savoir
que l'époque a changé fondamentalement
et que le souverainisme tel qu'il était
vu par le général de gaulle
il est difficilement applicable à une
planète qui est complètement ouverte
avec des échanges entre les hommes les
services et capitaux l'europe tel qu'il
l'avait conçue elle a peut-être un peu
évolué aussi parce qu'elle sait
tellement élargi alors est ce que est ce
que véritablement vous qu'on peut
appliquer les thèses du général de
gaulle les idées les doctrines à une
situation qui fondamentalement
différente aujourd'hui
alors d'abord le le goal a toujours tenu
compte des circonstances et il n'a
jamais promu la france seul le splendide
isolement
la france gaullienne elle était ouverte
elle était ouverte elle était dans
l'europe elle était dans le dans l'otan
elle était dans le monde dans l'économie
mondiale ça je ne faut pas caricaturer
ce qui a été la position du général de
gaulle et la souveraineté du peuple
l'indépendance de la nation elle se
forge et dans le monde comme il disait
tel qu'il était parmi les autres tels
qu'ils étaient bons alors si vous voulez
moi depuis depuis presqu'un demi siècle
j'entends répéter sans cesse la nation
c'est ringard les frontières c'est un
gars la souveraineté du peuple c'est
ringard l'état napoli au lien gaullien
c'est un gars le volontarisme économique
c'est ringard
le la sécurité sociale c'est un gars
bref tout cela serait ajouté d'ailleurs
a été jeté en grande partie à la
poubelle et on redécouvre que le monde
peut-être changé pendant cette période
mais il est en train de changer à
nouveau serré les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets quand vous
jetez tout ça par dessus bord
eh bien vous avez la catastrophe assurée
au bout aujourd'hui si on regarde les
changements du monde c'est le contraire
de ce que vous venez de de décrire les
frontières en reviennent les états
reviennent les souvent interviennent les
les demandes populaires partout dans le
monde vont à l'encontre de ce qui a été
fait qui a été décidée pendant des
décennies et des décennies qui viennent
de s'écouler regarder l'état du monde
regardait l'état catastrophique de
l'occident qui est en train de
s'écrouler sur lui même
regardez l'état catastrophique de notre
propre société de notre de notre pays et
écouter écouter la demande qui monte de
tous les peuples
alors elle peut avoir des expressions
caricatural je pense je pense par
exemple à donald trump
elle n'en demeure pas moins une demande
très forte d'une grande partie de
l'opinion on peut pas continuer comme ça
et quand on se retourne vers l'histoire
on voit bien que au fond ce qui nous
avait rendus que nous avons encore une
fois jetés par dessus bord nous en avons
de nouveau besoin aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'une autorité de l'état on a
besoin du volontariat savez le le
gaullisme c'est les deux choses qui
doivent aujourd'hui nous nous obséder
c'est la force que m'a rappelé la force
du nom dans l'histoire la capacité à
dire non
donc de gaulle ils surent pas de
l'europe mais quand ce qui se passe en
europe paraît contraire aux intérêts
vitaux de la france il fait la chaise
vide à bruxelles
voilà il sort pas de l'otan mais il sort
des organes militaires intégrées de
l'otan dans une époque c'est vrai
différentes delà de la note mais parce
qu'il veut bien être allié veut bien
trop fidèle allié il l'a toujours été
mais il veut pas que la france soit
entraînée dans une guerre dont elle ne
voudrait pas il veut pas que
l'alliance atlantique l'entraînent dans
dans une guerre sans que la france est
décidé que cette guerre était légitime
et qu'elle correspondait assez assez ses
engagements auprès de ses alliés il le
fait il le fait à strasbourg en 44 aussi
quand il refuse que plus strasbourg
soient évacués sur les ordres de l'état
major français
et parce qu'il veut voilà il veut pas il
veut pas que le mans d'offensives contre
offensives allemandes dans les ardennes
il leur en donne aux troupes françaises
de rester à strasbourg ça créé une grave
crise mais ils surent pas pour autant de
l'état major allié sûr pas de de
l'alliance avec les américains les
anglais mais il dit non et nous devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
bon ça devrait être écrit de salariés
écrit au dessus du bureau de chaque
responsable politique en particulier de
ceux qui se prétendent des hommes d'état
henri guaino je voulais pas vous vous
vous énervez je voulais pas vous fassiez
mais se sent qu'il ya un point sensible
mais je voudrais quand même vous posez
la question parce que je suis pas
totalement d'accord avec ce que vous ce
que vous expliquez sur la période
actuelle
il y a des pouvoirs aujourd'hui qu'ils
n'étaient qui n'existait pas sur le
temps du général de gaulle au siècle
dernier
il ya un pouvoir du consommateur mais
cela m'a organisé il ya un pouvoir des
actionnaires qui sera organisée
mais le consommateur il est quasiment
mondialisée aujourd'hui il fait ce qu'il
veut s'il veut aller acheter ses
bouquins shia amazon vous ne
l'empêcherait pas d'aller acheter ses
bouquins chez amazon ou dans le
e-commerce l'actionnaire jeu les fonds
de pension les fonds d'investissement
ils sont beaucoup plus puissants que les
fonds avec les fonds d'état ou que même
la caisse des dépôts aujourd'hui
non ils sont pas plus de puissance à
cette une
ça c'est une blague on a vu on a très
bien vu au moment de la crise financière
où cela pouvait nous mener simplement ce
sont pas les fonds de pension se sont
pas les marchés qui ont décidé de ne pas
aller plus loin dans la réforme de la
finance mondiale ce sont les gouvernants
moi j'ai assisté à tous les g20 de cette
époque là ce sont les gouvernants qui
ont compris des mesures quand il était
au pied du mur de la crise de la crise
financière puis qui ensuite ont lâché
non pas pour des questions d'intérêts
mais comme comme disait keynes pour des
question d'idées qu'elle disait c'est
pas tant les intérêts qu'ils vivent de
monde que les idées bon si les
gouvernements du g20 décidé de
réglementer un peu plus la finance
mondiale elle serait réglementée
voilà et personne ne pourrait ne
pourrait s'y opposer ce sont les
gouvernements et ce sont les idées qui
ne qui les gouvernent qui sont qui sont
en cause et c'est contre ça qu'il faut
qu'il faut se battre alors on se bat pas
toujours tout seul
il ya des choses qu'on peut faire pour
soi-même par exemple dire que là vous
regardez l'histoire des travailleurs des
travailleurs migrants en france en
europe
ça fait des années qu'on parle de ce
sujet vu qu'on n'arrive pas à le régler
vous savez on calcule les charges en
fonction des travailler en fonction du
lieu de pays européens d'origine et non
pas en fonction du pays d'accueil et
bien l'optimisation de nos partenaires
veulent pas changer rien n'empêche la
france rien n'empêche la france de
décider qu'elle mettra une taxe
supplémentaire sur chaque emploi
l'étranger que les entreprises
françaises utilisent et taxes
différentiel qui fasse que la charge
soit la même que pour les travailleurs
français
rien ne l'en empêche et personne ne
pourra l'obligé à ne pas appliquer cette
mesure personne voilà c'est ça s'appelle
la capacité à dire non et puis le jour
nos partenaires seront décidées enfin en
discuter alors nous irons en discuter
c'est exactement ce qu'a fait le général
de gaulle avec la politique de la chaise
vide sur la politique agricole commune
ça n'a pas tué la politique agricole
commune ça l'a sauvé et c'est pareil
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas changé ce qui me
ce qui attendait les attendez attendez
ce que je trouve absurde du baron de vue
intellectuel cessé de dire et bien sûr
il ya des choses qui changent bien sûr
le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfant
sujet
le bol et 1969 simplement il ya des
choses aussi qui ne changent pas ce qui
ne change pas ce sont les ressorts du
pouvoir ce qui ne change pas c'est ce
sont les valeurs fondamentales qu'un car
nous réussirons à incarner un pouvoir
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté voilà
ça pardonnez moi ça ne change pas trop
c'est un raisonnement que je sache
holisme je vous suis à général de gaulle
aujourd'hui aurait empêché la fermeture
de brian stone fabricant de pneus av
mais personne sensée mais mais pourquoi
moi je vais vous est proposé d' empêcher
les entreprises de faire mais en
revanche je crois que moi je veux pas
faire parler le général de gaulle le
général de gaulle il a toujours vécu
avec son temps bon aujourd'hui ce que je
ne comprends pas c'est que l'état sa
baisse à ce point c'est à dire que le
problème ait pas d'interdire aux gens de
faire mais personne ne peut leur
intérieur de fermer mais il ya manière
et manière c'est à dire que avoir trompé
tout le monde pendant des années ça
n'est pas acceptable et dire ce que
l'état on pense je m'en fiche
ça n'est pas acceptable non plus donc
est ce que l'état français veut se faire
respecter pour pouvoir prendre d'aidé
pour pouvoir négocier des délais et des
conditions et si peut pas négocier des
délais des conditions alors il peut
prendre des sanctions
voilà on n'est pas obligé d'importer
dans des démarches de l'âge de 9 ans
voilà c'est ce discours n'a qu il faut
tenir alors à ce moment là et là vous
avez là je vous suis vous avez vous un
objectif à un homme politique est ce
qu'il ya un responsable politique
aujourd'hui sur l'échiquier qui a ce
courage là aujourd'hui non mais non
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons hélas
dans la superficialité
si vous ne prenez pas si vous n'êtes pas
capable de prendre conscience de la
nature des crises auxquelles vous êtes
confrontés si vous n'êtes pas capable de
regarder la gravité de ces crises
je prends par exemple le la question de
du communautarisme du racialisme de
l'islamisme et c'est que c'est si vous
n'êtes pas capable de comprendre
il s'agit d'une guerre de civilisation
que l'on qu'il ya une volonté il ya des
forces qui se coalisent pour des de
l'extérieur et de l'intérieur de
l'intérieur aussi pour détruire là pour
détruire la civilisation occidentale
vous ne pouvez pas répondre à cette
crise c'est ça fait ça fait des
décennies qu'on se couche devant toutes
les minorités agissantes
et on n'est pas obligé on a la force du
nombre
l'histoire c'est dire non je me
coucherai pas devant les minorités
agissantes
je vais vous perdre son titre que sa
société et qui nous rend très
vulnérables à tous à toutes les forces
extérieures qui veulent la détruire
on a compris votre énergie sa
détermination c'est sûr des mois très
particulier sans gaullisme c'est c'est
la flamme vous savez c'est l'irruption
de la volonté humaine dans l'histoire
qu'incarne le général de gaulle et il
continue en ce sens un courant mais qui
n'est pas le seul il ya des courants
politiques très profonde très ancien qui
pensent le contraire voilà c'est au fond
vous savez au fond on est toujours
confronté même si les noms changent même
si les visages changent et incarnation
change au même choix en politique
le pétainisme où le gaullisme c'est à
dire ou bien je vous dis ah ben voilà on
va on va s'arranger comme si on pouvait
s'arranger avec hitler c'est ou bien on
dit on à la politique du courage la
politique de la peur d'un côté la
politique du courage de l'autre la
politique de la volonté d'un côté la
politique de la lâcheté de l'autre voilà
c'est on est toujours confronté à ça et
on a oublié qu'on était toujours
confronté à ça et bien regardez l'état
du monde de la société annonce henri
guaino henry verrez qu'on est confronté
à ça une fois de france henri guaino
lors des dernières présidentielles
1 là je repense à votre détermination
avant votre foulard lors des dernières
présidentielles vous aviez participé aux
sélections pour la présidence au premier
tour où les primaires je crois vous êtes
tenté à nouveau là maintenant j'avais
posé ma j'avais tout en étant non non
non parce que pour y aller il fallait
des parrainages que je n'ai pas obtenu
parce que le système était verrouillée
ben moi ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
quoi participer aux débats à ce moment
là et ça n'a pas été possible
c'est un x 7 x 2 yann est rejeté à
différentes proposées mais je n'en sais
rien pour l'instant je la question se
pose ne se pose pas nous verrons
souhaitera d'histoire dans les mois à
venir voyez bien le monde change tous
les jours mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
ça peut pas être une aventure solitaire
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut des
moyens ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut
des parrainages
même quand vous passez pas par les
primaires primaires qui ont détruit tous
les tous les partis de gouvernement
parce qu'elle était totalement contraire
à l'esprit de la vème république enfin
ça aussi c'est si on veut penser un peu
au gaullisme il n'y a pas de candidat
des partis dans le gaullisme dans le
gaullisme il ya des candidats qui
peuvent être soutenus par des partis
qui ne sont pas les représentants des
partis c'est ça c'est la dénaturation de
la vème république
5e un public on l'a dénaturé on l'a
affaibli on a fait le quinquennat on a
on a détruit le service public on attend
et on s'étonne aujourd'hui que l'état de
ma ne fonctionne pas que nos
institutions fonctionnent mal mais on
les a tellement abîmée mais on les a
abîmé par pour des raisons techniques
pas pour des raisons juridiques on les a
abîmé par ce que il y avait un
renoncement philosophique spirituelle
morale qui nous a conduit à cette
situation
henri guaino je ne continuerai pas à
vous interroger sur ce terrain là parce
que je sens qu on y reviendra parce que
vous avez terriblement envie de
participer à ce débat là pour les
prochaines présidentielles je suis sûr
qu'on vous dira en économie je suis pas
un économiste suis pas pour la fermeture
je suis maintenant non non non
collectivisme je suis pas pour le
dirigisme voilà mais on n'est pas obligé
pour autant d'abandonner tout
volontarisme ça ça me paraît une
ossements dans le monde qui vient vous
êtes rendu plus délétère que dans le
monde physique que nous sommes en train
de quitter
je rappelle le titre de votre livre un
de gaulle le nom qui nous manque ou le
nom de tout ce qui nous manque aux
éditions du rocher
alors c'est un livre qu'on peut
commander en librairie merci beaucoup on
retrouve cette émission merci on la
retrouve rediffusion sur l'antenne mais
aussi sur tous les réseaux sociaux et
sur le site internet
rt france poi poi tva les a très vite
merci henri
[Musique]